[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
[Musique]
au revoir
Wow
Whatsapp
bien
cacao
et ceci
[Musique]
cette chance
quoi de neuf
moi seulement
Whatsapp
Wow
[Applaudissements]
parce que nous sommes ici encore seulement
équipe d'action à partir de zéro pour voir comment
logiciel express
[Musique]
Oui
où la ligne
[Musique]
NOUS
Je ne cherchais pas de postes
offre toujours veut associer le droit
maritime
Alors
[Musique]
h
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la soul team ne se lasse pas peut
avec lequel
[Musique]
je
habitent
J'en ai marre des nouvelles barbes
avec elle
plus
Oui
Voyons voir
et
beaucoup cher
je veux partir
le sourire
Pas le choix
mais non
non
m
mais
Wow
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et pas toujours ces systèmes systèmes
moi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh
[Musique]
à présent
Oh
[Musique]